now I want to do this the first thing I
want to do is just highlight this story
to give us some contemporary context
this is from Fox News Washington DC
removes Cuba Libre Street painting from
in front in front of the Cuban Embassy
Embassy located in the same street where
mayor Bowser ordered painting last year
of black lives matter
I gotta say I was actually shocked to
see this even though I know the biases
of the establishment I know that they
support black lives matter I know the
black lives matter activists say they're
marxists I was still surprised to see
that they would be as Brazen as to
remove Cuba Libre from the street they
painted black lives matter they had no
approval they took the tax money they
painted it this just shows you the the
degree to which the establishment in the
U.S is in favor of the Communist
dictatorship of Cuba and it is very
scary to me we also have this story
Nicole Hannah Jones said Cuba most equal
Western Country in a podcast the funny
thing is it's also AOC it's also other
Progressive Democrats saying that oh the
real problem is the Embargo it's not
communism
so I wanna I wanna I wanna I need to
understand right I can see what's
happening here in the US I can see the
changes that are happening but I'm
interested uh you know so you you you're
both activists uh Jose you were actually
born into a free and Democratic Cuba how
old were you when the Communists took
over I was 18 years old
not when the Communists when the
revolution took over
it was never intended to have a
socialist Revolution
taking power and remaining in power for
six to more than 62 years
so I was 18 years old I had just
graduated from the Maris Brothers with a
bachelor of uh with a degree on Bachelor
Arts
and I were planning to attend Havana
University to a story United journalism
and law
and uh so you know both basically what
took over was a big lie
so so how big of a deal when you you
were 18 when the revolution happened but
that wasn't a Communist Revolution
fall down Escape Cube and Fidel too
all the marriage of the Revolution that
had been also launched by other
organizations and by other leaders and
other movements but in 1959 Fidel was
able to control
all the power of himself
and being a great speaker and a huge
liar he gained
total supporting you that is the truth
in 1959 but right after that his big
life began to dismantle
and the truth
came out and then those same people that
were with him fighting batita that
worked with him in Sierra Mitra like
uber Matos 10 months after he took power
tool Fidel companero Fidel
I cannot continue
in the way the revolution is going I
don't want to be an obstacle to you
I want to become a teacher again
before I went to the Sierra Matra
I want to be a teacher again
and good luck with the revolution
that's when the big lie really became an
oppressive
totalitarian idea of eliminating anybody
who descend with you and that's when
Fidel Castro sent to come away where
Huber mactos who was in charge of the
military
the chief of the army
and with orders of apprehending him
and taking him to Havana
accusing him on National radio Fidel
when he sang Camille over there that you
were Matos was a traitor
and when Camilo sinfuego got to come
away and saw over Matos peaceful in his
home with his family and his kids
he had not rebelled against the
revolution
decided to tell over to stay here I
gotta go back and talk to Fidel and then
more lies began to continue then
they shut down Camilo because it's
Camilo dinofaro Castro's other orders of
happy apprehending over matters
and then they killed camilos in fuegos
and people that started I started to
blame you were matters on the Fidel
Direction now the responsible for
killing over Matos was over too
how did I get to that point how did the
revolution happen
the revolution happened was very simple
and was a tremendous excuse
for Castro
atita March 10 1952
who had been by the way I would say a
good president in 1940
from 1944 he was actually an elected
president in Cuba before he threw his
coup d'etat and came into power so
that's like a little fact that maybe a
lot of people don't don't know so with
an excuse you know of of uh
saving the country from fraud in the
upcoming elections batita a few months
before Brio ended was running his
presidency a new elections were coming
in he decided to to start a a revolution
based on that on the good data on the
coup data and from that that was the
excuse and this is why it's sad to to
say that maybe Batista was not as bad as
people blame him to be during those
seven years
but the truth of the matter is that we
saw batita and the good excuse to Fidel
to use the coop data as an issue for his
Revolution
nothing will happen in Cuba because
Fidel did not have Fidel had tried to be
in the political atmosphere in to be
part of a political party to be elected
in elections for small positions and he
never won anything
the 26th of July of 1953 that was in
1952 the coup d'etat in 26 July of 1953
he attacked the moncada barracks he
brings there a lot of young Cubans who
were very ideally idealists
and many of them died there but he
gained a name
and from that day was born the 26th of
July revolutionary movement so the the
Batista yeah he he was claiming there
was fraud in the election but the attack
claimed that he interrupted the
elections that were all coming because
they were going to be fraudulent
and with that excuse
he gave the coup d'ata of course nobody
believe him
these things the interesting thing if
people want to think about this is that
batita was in power he was a dictator
but he didn't mess with the media
he didn't mess with the business
he didn't mess with Enterprises
he just wanted to make some money and be
again a figure in Cuba
but you know that that that basically
did not affect it at all
the development of Cuba from 1953 or
1952 to 1959 Cuba continued to grow
Cuba continued to develop businesses
gonna Cuba continue to raise the
standard of living of the Cuban people
the problem with the socialism and with
the revolution the total the
totalitarian Revolution is not only that
they seek power
is that they destroy everything
and it's very clear and I are not here
to defend but it I'm telling you what
Theta was
sadly enough
the good skills of Fidel have to do all
these things that he did there's there's
a lot of similarities there to what
we're seeing in the US now Donald Trump
well I mean he's not he's not the
fascist dictator that Batista may have
been but Donald Trump has that hatred
the excuse the excuse they use Society
feels it yeah to claim that they need
power they need new laws they need to
shut down their their political
opposition quell dissent go after the
extremists
arrest them expand uh Federal resources
and power and law I mean you look at
what they've been saying about the far
right about militia groups and the
threat of white supremacy and uh of
course it's not identical there's a few
things that I that I that that's that
feel similar you have this guy Trump
they call him a dictator they call him a
fascist but he didn't aside from
insulting the media yeah he didn't shut
down the Press he may have banned them
from some of his events he didn't call
in the military to go and Crush protests
or anything like that certainly has his
issues but because of of what the media
said about him because of the view
people had about him
the Democrats now you know getting
elected are using as an excuse for
basically everything among other things
to be completely honest so my fear is
obviously we have we have a lot of
different things that are happening in
the US outside of just the you know
politics we have coveted with the
pandemic you know lockdowns and things
like that are coming thanks for checking
out this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time